[Music]
it's a long established fact that
learning new information can cause your
brain to forget
old information but when you learn new
things
what exactly do you lose let's find out
in america's favorite new game show
[Music]
hi i'm derek davis and this is what did
you lose
please welcome today's contestant amber
ruffin
hi i'm amber i'm from omaha nebraska i
love nachos and i'm excited to be here
we're excited to have you amber you know
how this works
we'll show you a piece of information
you've learned over the last four years
and then we'll show you something that
you used to know if you can identify
both
you get a point are you ready i'm ready
here we go
the members of president trump's staff
and cabinet have been in the news a lot
over the past four years and americans
have had to learn a lot of their names
amber who is this
michael flynn he's president trump's
former national security adviser
who pleaded guilty for lying to the fbi
that's correct and who is this
oh i know this uh no
i don't i'm sorry that's your fifth
grade teacher mrs kahn
oh next question who's this
that's scott pruitt he was the head of
the epa under president
trump but he was forced to resign
because he was under 14
different federal investigations that's
correct
and what is this uh oh i know
is it the date trump withdrew from the
paris agreement
nope it's your aunt lolo's birthday oh
it's also today's date oh crap i have to
call her later
bonus question who's this no idea that's
your aunt lolo
next question amber what is this
that's president trump's custom sharpie
he likes sharpies so much that he called
the company
and asked them to make him quote one
that looks rich
and then he used it to falsify a map of
a hurricane
that's correct and what is this
uh wait i know what that is uh how crazy
i forgot the word for it um
you know paper chumpy chopper paper
choppy jumper
yes final answer stapler
oh the answer we were looking for is
stapler of course how could i have
forgotten all of this
because you've absorbed so much dumb
information from the trump
administration you've forgotten
everything else
gross oh that sound means it's the end
of round one and so far amber has zero
points
i thought i would do a lot better than
this i don't know why after four years
all of our brains are mush lightning
round
this round is just like the first round
but faster and it's amber's chance to
turn things around i can do it
here we go who's this stephanie clifford
an adult film star who goes by the stage
name stormy
daniels name this shape a s
steve bannon not even close who's this
mark
esper former secretary of defense who
trump fired last week
what's this cafe you remember confefe
but not uneven bars why would i know
uneven bursts you used to be a
gymnastics coach
i did that sounds fun who's this
reince priebus former white house chief
of staff
who's this never seen her before in my
life
and that's time remember to join us
again next week and remember to call
your aunt lolo who
thanks for playing america's favorite
new game show
[Music]
[Applause]
you